you go with these cartels these
cartilages bro
like you find shrines dedicated to these
to these gins bro
like shrines and and and what they do
with what the
with with the the rival cartels
like they'll skin them alive and they'll
put body parts on
on like around this around this this gin
that's how demonic these these people
are
probably that's why
i i was like at the end of the at the
end of my ride with the cartels
i would think to myself oh my god yeah
i'm certain there's evil
i'm 100 sure that evil exists that the
devil exists that all these demons exist
because i've seen it firsthand i see how
they work
there there has to be something there
has to be a good in this world there has
to be something that is right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i think if somebody wants a good
character
the easiest way the easiest way to
achieve that as fast as possible
is empathy because what is what is good
character good character is a reflection
of who you are and how you treat other
people
podcast in the dunya we are joined here
today with your regular host the three
muslims
and we're joined with a very special
guest for the second time
brother zach salam
how are you how are you doing i'm doing
pretty well i think thank you for asking
but i hope you guys are doing
pretty well as well alhamdulillah allah
has been blessing us brother
i want to thank especially the people
that have been donating for this course
i you guys have no idea how much how
much heart you guys are putting into
this and
and how much you trust you know it's
something very incredible
may allah bless all you guys that are
helping us out uh with this with this
project
and inshallah everything will go as
smooth and we'll be able to do what we
have to do you know
[Music]
bro a lot of people are like who is zach
who is this
fun brother bro and y'all i just have to
say that we filmed an episode with him
um a few days ago for you when you guys
are watching this but
he is an ex cartel member high-ranking
ex-cartel member
who was guided rightfully by the will of
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala to assam
and we filmed an insane episode with him
so i'm going to put this up right here
if you guys missed that out give that a
watch but this time
what are we going into bro into jail
activity
into what really runs in in that low
life
um bro people would be like
they don't even know what jin is do you
think that's the case like they don't
know what
like the actual things are called jin or
do you think they're just like
they know they're like spirits and you
know demons or whatever
i'm basically learning about uh the
terminology of gin and how they're
whether
they work right but when i was in in
that life
like we call them uh they call them by
different names you know spirits saints
demons a lot of people call them demons
you know straight out what they what
they are you know like
they know that they're making they're
making deals with the devil at the end
they understand that but some people
just like um
they don't really understand what the
terminology of jinn is because now we
know as muslims we know that there's
this there's two creations right us as
humans and and the jinn kind
uh but they they they just believe that
the jinn is just like that
them well you can say it that way it's
like they're they're just uh
demonic beings you know uh some people
don't see them that way some people
think that they're
that they help uh that's when when we
get involved into all these saints that
we see here with the cartels because
every specific uh
every specific leader has has a has a
certain
certain saint that he he worships and he
he's loyal to
but at the end of the day we know that
those are jinns you know
yeah that's insane bro it's found a lot
so how do they see it do they actually
see it as saints as people who are
helping and aiding them
or is that just like a um mask
to my personal experience like when i
started getting like when i started
meeting all these people you know like
uh hitman and all this like
you would see that they would carry uh
their attachment you know
uh the one that's most famous with
sicarios is is
the death supposedly holy dead there's
nothing holy right
but that's the one that really has
influence over
everyone almost everyone you would see
other type of other type of um
of saints like saint judah uh in spanish
they call him
uh he's a really he's he's uh
he's somewhat important for for these
people you know these cartel members
but yeah they um
i think it's not the connection like
them actually having having experiences
like
like like the ones that we've seen and
the ones that i've
i've been able to experience now that
i'm a muslim it's it's more like um
they they blindly follow these these
deities right
they blindly follow these things these
gins without knowing what they're doing
they're
they're asking favors they're putting um
they're putting special treats to them
in some cases like they'll they'll even
put a life you know
the promise of life towards them and for
them to fulfill their wishes
and i've seen that it does it does
happen bro but it always has a really
bad ending to that
story so yeah that's what i've seen
[Music]
and that's that's exactly what is taught
in islam there is actually a story of um
i forget the name but it was a jewish
scholar and subhanallah i'm going to
make the long story very short he
basically had to take care of
these three guys as sister so he started
very slowly you know
leaving food at her door eventually he
went inside he ended up committing
zinna with her he ended up murdering her
and the baby burying them
and then shaytan came to him at the end
when he's being dragged away and like
being brought to
be put to death and he's like i'm
shaytaan
i'm the one who put you in this i'm the
only one who can get you out
if you want me to save you from this you
have to pray to me
and then i'll save you from it he ended
up praying to satan
and then satan left and the man was
killed
on the spot and that's the essence of
people who deal with the jinn
they do these nasty things these
horrific rituals they make these
promises
and they live a disgusting life and all
the time
all the time it ends up in this way i
i've heard i've heard a lot of
of like what you're saying right now i
heard a lot man like
i'm gonna give you an example i met this
guy that he had like he had a bunch of
hotels right
and he was paying he was paying money to
the cartels so basically the cartels
they
they go to your business and they tell
you like hey you're gonna have to pay
this much money
and then basically they'll give you like
a monthly fee
and if you pay we're gonna protect you
if not we'll start closing your
businesses right
but this guy had like everybody knew in
town that he had done
he had he had a pact with a devil that
he had sacrificed his kids
he had given his kids in in sacrifice
for
for all his riches you know and at the
end what basically happened to end
to him was he was taken by the cartels
and he was killed because
they they wanted to get more money from
him he couldn't he couldn't get the
money the people that he was
the people that were with him weren't
loyal to him and they didn't
they they rather had him killed than
help him out or
or try to sell what he had to save his
life they basically left them alone
um now there's something really crazy
but like i
i used to listen to a lot of music right
mexican music i don't know if you guys
are familiarized with corridos you know
corridors are
basically the narco music what what what
uh marco's
here right and in all these songs like
there's there's always a specific part
where they talk about
i made i sold myself to them and we hear
this in in pop music as well you know
but that's how you notice that it's it's
it's all it's it's
all like almost all the music industry
goes back to the same thing
and in spanish like you hear this like
in mexican music
like that they're at the end and they
sell their songs to the devil and now
that the devil is giving them everything
um a couple of times like i'm gonna be
honest with you guys right
before i i was i was an ignorant into
what i was doing
but i would i would always hear stories
like this cave they call this cave the
cape of the devil and if you go there
at the middle of the night like you can
go in and you can you can call upon the
devil and the devil will show up
and you'll make a deal with him and
you'll come out with with money and all
this right
a couple times we're like just messing
around me and some friends we would go
and we're like
let's see if he comes out he never came
out you know um and now i know why
because
allah was taking care of me he never let
me let me he never let me have that type
of connection with with santan right
so yeah i'm definitely that's something
that's very
very famous here in mexico everywhere
you go you hear this like
that people have gone into that to that
lifestyle
and they they ended up doing packs with
them but
it's like everything there's nothing
good on the back and at the end it's
it's gonna pay its price it's just your
life
so while you were while you were in that
right
in in the hotel did you notice any type
of
inner fitra feeling from you that
what's going on here isn't really right
it's not what it should be
or was it more like it was just everyone
was doing it it was cloudy
no uh because first like i said i was an
atheist
i didn't really believe in anything like
i was like
yeah right but there is there is you
know that's when
when when your fitrah comes in you
actually you you have to sit down and
say
all right if evil exists if all these
things exist then there should be
something good
because at the end like you you
how can i say this you notice where
where all those roads are ending up
you know how all these people end up and
people that that pray to these people
that pray to these these jinns they know
like they they're
they know world like they're they're
conscious of what's gonna happen
that they'll that they're gonna help
them out for for quite some time
at the end of the day they're gonna
leave them alone
so the question that pops into my head
next is
we hear a lot about people who interact
with jinn and who use them and who are
used by the jinn
do you have any groups of muslims that
are doing rookia and working against
this stuff
dealing with exorcisms and black magic
and or anything like that
uh no not at the moment wow
yeah i'm basically where
i have some brothers with this going on
with the dingy show and everything
like they they've got in contact with me
and they're helping me out you know but
basically
i had to learn like by myself you know
but by the guidance of the law and
and to see by the experiences that i was
seeing right the experiences that i was
having
like sometimes i would hear people
whistle inside my house you know
i would be doing something and i would
hear whistles or what we were hearing uh
what angel was hearing on the last show
you know or people knocking on the
window
people walking around you you feel that
you you get that
that evil vibe and when i was in the
cartels i didn't
i didn't really feel it but but you
would notice like
like you would notice right so when when
i was in the prison
um
[Music]
but certain people like were talking
would talk to me right they were telling
me like hey
there's something there's something
taking care of you there's a black
shadow behind you
and everywhere i would sleep like um
the the the the santa muerte the this
this this gin
it would it would it would paint itself
right here on the back everywhere i
would sleep bro i
would they were able to it would like
the shadow would be there
and they would tell me like so something
is taking care of you or something is
there you know
and i was i was very like
i was superstitious about it yeah i
don't think so i don't think so
but then getting involved in this like i
didn't really
i didn't have i didn't know better right
but i was like i was letting myself
be guided by these gins right and
you would see like you would see that
they would they would do favors you know
like i would ask favors and the favors
would come back
um but then like i would see that like
i would i could feel i would get that
feeling like sometimes i'll get that bad
that bad vibe that if if if this really
exists and this is really happening to
me if these genes are
are are manifesting here then there
should be something that is that is good
right there there should be
there there should be that's something
that the of all there should be
something that's opposite to what to
what we're seeing inside of prisons and
that
and like i said in prison like that's
what that's all that's
that's everyday life you live in that
there was a
certain i got to a certain place right i
got to maximum security
i'm talking about when i was two years
in prison i had already been through a
lot of things
but i had never i have never had a i had
never had a
an altar or a holy death right and when
i got there
the the person that i got there he had a
holy death on the top and
he would put he would put candles and i
asked him like can i can i turn her
candle on her and he's like yeah for
sure
and i put it and i asked him like i just
asked for like for money right because i
i was going through a hard time in there
and yeah like
the main characters inside of prison
they would they would uh
they would have like huge huge places
just dedicated
for these for these gins um
these people ended up doing a big ride
in there and then
like 11 people got killed 12 people got
killed and the main the main person that
was inside of prison he got his head cut
off inside of prison
and the enemies were playing basketball
with him like that bro
and everybody like when when all that
happened
they started cleaning the they started
cleaning the maximum security area
like they started washing the blood away
bro like you could feel that
that vibe inside there and and people
were saying like
you know why this happened i would like
i'll be like why because she's like
today is today is that
today because you know how they
celebrate their birthday or
like the jen's birthday that it was it
was her birthday
so it was that particular saints
birthday and like everybody was saying
no it's like
she plays with hers that's that's the
same
she claims what's hers and these these
specifically these specific people that
god that got killed bro
they had been in prison for 20 years
right they had been the worst of the
worst
you know how much time they had left for
them to go free bro
three months for them to go free and
they were out of prison
these people that got murdered by the
same but by the same population inside
of prison
they had three months to leave and you
were like that's weird right like you'd
be like
yeah right it gives you goosebumps to
know that that that these genes
work that way and it is true like that
that's how they work they they lead you
they they give you crumbs so you can
follow them and they lead you
straight to to a certain death because
they
they
were there were people that were that
were like really hardcore into that bro
really hurtful arrangement but like yeah
i would see that in prison
uh and the car tells us it's a little
bit different but it's basically the
same thing but inside a prison like
they have nothing else they have nothing
else in prison so basically that's
that these saints are everything for
them uh
they they the three basically the three
basic saints that are in there is the
virgin mary
like everybody a catholic any catholic
is going to believe in the virgin mary
but it's very strong here in mexico
uh the the holy death and saint saint
judah
and like they will make talismans from
from human bone
from metal and from gold you know and
you would see people that were really
into this like hardcore and you you you
feel that by
you know like you would walk into a
place and you would see all these images
and all the
all the shirts being done inside and and
you would get that like
i i didn't believe it but i would see
things you know and i would see that all
the people that were in charge
were faithful to this to this gin
at the end it's a gen you know but it's
like and and i got involved into that i
got i got drawn into it so i would also
carry around
my my amulet you know and i would say
like it's taking care of me
but it was it was leading me to a very
dark path bro
damn bro i'm over here thinking
because like your bro your story i had a
friend who used to tell me
that um there was something
in his life that was like protecting him
or something that was doing something
and he said like every time he would
take a picture
there was always this blur in the image
somewhere in the image it was either
like behind him
beside him or like somewhere in front or
something but there was always this blur
like he could never take a picture where
it was like completely clear
and that's it it was always like there
was a blur
and to this day he says that it's
something there
something there and bro
you wanna know the craziest thing
i'm not gonna say all the details
because i don't wanna put this man on
blast
it's his life you know it's what he went
through
but when he decided that he no longer
wanted to do what he was doing he was
doing some some pretty uh
sus things in terms of uh
not counterfeiting but scamming and i
won't say like what kind of scams i'm
just saying
scamming and uh when he decided that he
didn't want to do it anymore
bro he got busted by the police and he
had to go to jail
and he's he's out now alhamdulillah and
he's actually starting to like
go on to the spiritual path i've been
trying to like give him dawah in there
but it's like he said the same thing
where it's like
they said about you that there was like
this this shadow or something like that
and bro you weren't here you were
actually frozen but i was telling fire
that um when i worked at uh this
this supplement store i i i'm not gonna
say the name it because though
they'll probably like try me or
something for uh you know you know how
it is
the fortune teller right yeah did i tell
you that
but i listened to it and i forgot to
like give you the full explanation of
why i told the brother but um
the same thing that happened to you
happened to me but i didn't finish i
didn't get to finish everything right so
this is what happened when i was in the
house i didn't believe in in this right
when i was before
that sometimes you before i went into
prison i was still a cartel member
but i didn't believe in anything i
wasn't believing anything i was just
like just doing my business handling
my stuff believing that i was gonna it
was just a matter of luck and a matter
of
of of of mentality you know if you have
that mentality that you're going to die
you're going to die if
you haven't if you have a weak mentality
you're not you're not going to be able
to handle
the business that you're that you're
doing but
this gives me goosebumps bro so when i
went to this party and i met this person
he was like something really bad is
going to happen to you know
yeah whatever he gave me as an example
this this kid that ended up murdering
his his uh his girlfriend
and when i went into prison i asked him
and he confirmed that you know he's like
yeah he's going to be careful with this
person
four four months later like i was
actually counting bro since the day he
told me that i
had four months like i didn't believe in
it but i was counting the time and i was
making my my uh my accounts you know i
was thinking like
okay i have to i have to make sure that
this month i'll be extra careful because
something's going to happen
i was falling into that bro i told the
brother
i had a dream bro and in that dream um i
got shot in the face and i got shot in
the in
the arm and i ended up in the street and
i ended up
like that was my first dream right and
then the the
i in the same dream i got sucked into a
dark room
like a black room and in this black room
there was uh
there was roots coming down like the uh
the roots of a tree
but it was dark like very dark bro and
this voice this
these two eyes red eyes but like i would
hear the voice started talking to me
and they started asking me what do you
want in this life
but a very evil demonic voice
was asking me what do you want in this
life and and i
and i said i want power and i want my
freedom
he's like what are you going to do for
it i was like i'm going to do anything
i ain't afraid of doing anything because
i wasn't afraid right i wasn't even
afraid of talk like he having this
experience with this
with this creature and then he told me
walk up the stairs and i didn't i didn't
mention this on on on on the last
podcast but when i was walking up the
stairs
he told me look look look at like and
down the stairs
on the side of the black wall there was
pictures right
he told me look at those pictures and i
turned my head and i looked at the
pictures and i saw the the
holy day i saw the virgin mary i saw
baphomet the one that the the half sheep
half woman
i saw a bunch of demons bro and that
voice told me like i am
all those he's like i control this world
i'm in control of this world
and i appear back in the dream that the
dream itself was
the second the third dream has nothing
to do with some crazy stuff
but when i woke up brother
allows my witness that half of my face
was numb bro like if i had really got
shot here
and i couldn't lift up my arm because it
was numb
[Music]
fast forwarding everything like i would
ask myself right like
what's what kind of meaning was that you
know what was the meaning
it basically was you have two ways or
you follow
you follow the the gin and then you end
up
giving giving like letting them give you
whatever you want
or you can acknowledge that there's a
creator and that something was
protecting me
because at the end of the day nothing
happened to me in those four months
do you understand that what this what
this fortune teller was telling me he
was telling me what was gonna happen to
me if i followed
the the steps i was following but that's
when
allah took me out of the streets and put
me into prison
i didn't understand you know i i didn't
understand what was going on at the time
because like
you you sometimes you don't you you
can't
you you you your mind is not capable of
of understanding because you're in that
environment right you're not even paying
attention to it
but now that i'm standing here as a
muslim and i turn around
brother i get goosebumps bro just
knowing how how my
how my creator has been taking care of
me and how merciful he has been with me
because he took me out of he took me out
of the streets just to make sure that
nothing happened to me
now with the shadow that i'm talking to
about
this would be in every cell i would go
like it didn't matter if i was sleeping
underneath a table
on the top of the of the top the shadow
would would paint itself bro
and there was people that would worship
this particular saint and they were
tumbling
there's something there's something
taken care of now i learned like um
my my grandma she's uh she's a christian
right
but she believes in all these witchcraft
because there's a lot of witchcraft
going down here
and she told me once she she actually
told me she's like did you know that
that you're cursed i'm like what are you
talking about on chris
she's like yeah a very uh a very high
priest
in in the demonic in the witchcraft
world he put a curse on you and he put
it chris on your mom he put a chris
on all our family and like supposedly
this chris was
supposed to lead us astray and all this
right uh
that explains a lot of what happened
what happened to my mom when we were
when we were young i told you guys what
happened right you guys remember
i was telling you guys the situation
that i that we had with my father and
like that would explain that and that
was explaining to where i was leading
myself
into inside a prison when
the the strange part was that like the
people that would help me would be
what would be believers in the same and
they would help me like
really they were trying to help me um i
knew like
i knew someone was trying to do harm on
me like they were doing they were doing
the evil eye they were doing witchcraft
on me
trying to make sure that i was i was
gonna end up dead you know
because when i left when i left prison
and i was in the cartels
a certain friend came up to me he told
me he's like hey um this priest wants to
do a cleaning on you
it's basically they clean you right from
any evil evil work that they're doing on
you and
he said yeah but he he clarified he's
like but
he's saying that if if the saint that
you have on your neck if
if they're working you with that that
he's not going to be able to save you
now even in prison bro when i was in
prison
when i was getting tatted when i was
when i was like because i got tired in
prison right
when i was getting tired bro like i
would look at myself and i would be like
oh they would be telling me and i'd be
sitting right there and i would look at
myself and i would see myself get
dismembered
like for real bro like our like in my
mind
that that that um that image would never
leave
i would see myself get dismembered and
in in in the image that i had in my mind
i would see myself really tied up like
my goal when i was in prison
like i have i have a lot of tattoos
but my my goal was to just completely
cover my
my full body with tattoos right my neck
everything
but in that image like i would see
myself covered with tattoos and
everything but i would see myself
getting dismembered
now a couple of people when i went out
of prison they would tell me like
take care of yourself like this like god
has been good with you like not they
weren't muslims but they were just
letting you know you know god has been
good with you like you've survived for
so long
and you know that in this business
nobody survives that long they
they end up dying three years four years
they end up in prison for the rest of
their life
bro allah had already saved me from
prison for 20 30 years of prison
and i was still so i was still i was
still being
being ignorant and arrogant to what what
his plan was for me
and i still ran back to that life you
know and and
a couple of people were coming they were
telling me hey we see yourself getting
killed
like we we dream with you getting killed
a lot of people told me that like they
were telling me like we we
we dreamed that you got shot in the face
this and that
there was a specific uh specific thing
uh a girl called me up right she's like
hey are you okay i was like yeah why
she's like i dreamed that you got
dismembered that you got cut up into
pieces
um that's the worst way you can die bro
inside a pre inside of the cartels
because they don't they don't kill it
they don't they don't shoot you in the
head and they cut you up
no they cut your hands and they burn you
so you won't blood so you won't beat out
and they'll torture you they'll cut you
piece by piece and then they'll make
sure to to uh
to burn those spots so so you won't you
won't bleed
out right brother it's some
demonic things that they do and and and
like don't they'll keep your ear
like they'll keep your ear they'll keep
pieces of your of your body and they
will go in and put them
on these saints on these things right
but this girl told me she's like you're
going to get this remembered like i saw
you get dismembered i was like what
explain to me what was the dream she's
like uh in this place
she gave me the name of the place and i
knew that place right
i was like it's cool don't worry about
it if i'm gonna die with that fighting
because i knew like
well i would carry my pistol at the end
of the at the end of my at the end of my
uh
the the the charger that the the what's
it called yeah
we say what's it what's the name of it
in english
we know it has but for the like the gun
the clip yeah there you go the clip yeah
the clip
the the last two bullets bro there would
be um
what are they called uh hollow point
because uh a full metal jacket is even
if you shoot yourself you can shoot
yourself and you'll still survive
i've seen brothers get shot here here in
the neck and nothing happens
but with the hollow point once it hits
it's gonna it's gonna expand and
nothing is left like you're you're
taking
blow your head off so i knew that if
anything happened i i had those two
hollow points and those two hollow
points were for me
because i wasn't gonna let myself get
get caught by the by the cartels like i
would kill myself with the government
but by the cartels if i ran out of
bullets or anything happen
i would put a bullet in my you know on
me but
look how look how corrupt was my
mentality that i was ready to do that
from
like i i i would go out working with
this mentality if anything happens if
something goes wrong
if the cartels want to get me i'm not
going to let myself get tortured
because i would see people get tortured
bro the same for
for this cartel and you would see
friends that would get caught up like
friends that would go
see their family and they would get
caught by the cartels and then
like oh i don't know if you guys see but
there's videos bro like this is how this
is how corrupt these people are
they'll take a video of you getting
tortured and they'll send it to your
family
or they'll post it on the internet
they'll brag about it on facebook
that's how bad it is bro so i knew that
i hadn't i had to put a book i had to
put a bullet in me i wasn't gonna let
myself get caught up
this place that this girl mentioned look
at the
the the gin activity in my life how gen
how the gyms were working
they were leading me to this right in
that same spot
where she said that she saw me get
dismembered
we were coming back from from from a
business and we get ambushed
in this place remember in the last
interview i was telling you guys that i
got stuck
that i was trying to take my that was
trying to take the seat belt and i got
stuck inside
and i stuttered for a couple of moments
while the bullets were flying
that's the spot that she saw that she
said she saw she saw me get
uh get dismembered i didn't i did it bro
dreams don't come to you just because
i didn't know like that's why i come
back to the same thing now that i step
outside
and i turn my turn around and i look on
my left hand
i get goosebumps bro and i just like i
start crying bro i start crying
like a real man i start crying just to
know how merciful allah has been with me
just to know that he's protecting me
every single step i've given
bro that day look how crazy things were
right
i'm gonna get a little bit into detail
about what happened this day
like we were in a solid road of like no
lights
nothing wrong like you couldn't get
ambushed right
i don't know where brother this truck
comes running behind us
like trying to chase us we're cartel
members we're not stupid we're not gonna
get into a gunfight with with the
military when you know the military is
just gonna
straight out eliminate you so you're
gonna you have to be smart and we were
thinking like
we were i was the one driving and the
the brothers i had in the back they were
like
is it military it's a military like
let's verify if it's military if it's
military let's miss bounce let's leave
the car let's run
and the other person is like nine
they're not military they're probably
they're probably
other cartel another cartel trying to
kill us let's just get off and start
start shooting and i was like so what do
we do
let's start like i'll stop the car and
we'll get off and we'll start we'll
start hitting them you know if they're
military then we'll run
but we were getting into such a
confusion like they couldn't like we
couldn't get
we we couldn't get into one single
single mindset like okay okay stop the
car let's get off let's do this
now we were panicking bro because on the
other side of the road
four trucks were coming in
these people they start shooting us as
they start shooting they didn't turn on
they didn't turn on the the siren they
didn't tell us to
to to to to stop didn't do anything
these were corrupt these were corrupt uh
corrupt uh
police members right because they were
yeah they were
state police they were these were
corrupt bro now i'm explaining why
because they they in mexico like the a
normal cop
they can't shoot you unless they see
that that you should that you've shot
back or that you have an arm
a gun but you're driving and another and
somebody comes behind you and starts
shooting at you bro
and you're going to think that it's it's
it's another gang or it's another cartel
right
when they start shooting at us the
brothers start getting like they start
panicking and they start preparing
themselves to to start fighting
when we start seeing three uh four other
trucks coming down on the other side
where we had to where we had to get out
they were closing us in right
so we end up crashing we end up getting
off and we end up
getting into a gunfight with them the
other four trucks hearing that that was
we started getting into a gunfight and
i'm talking like like a gunfight bro not
not just shooting one two no like
wasting three four bags on on this on
these people
and and them shooting back we we get to
we escape and we see how these
these these other trucks are coming in
right
we can save everything is everything's
cool um we end up
spending like two days hiding in the
mountains bro because like the marines
and everybody was looking for us
because of what had happened um
a month passes and and i talked to
someone i had someone in that
in the government as well right and then
i told him hey what happened like who
were the people that were trying to kill
us
he's like you're not going to believe it
bro but that day they weren't going to
arrest you guys
they were there to kill you guys they
were there to dismember you because the
two of the two of the trucks that were
coming in on the other side
there were cartel members the rival
cartel and they had paid the government
to capture us and to give us up to them
do you understand do you see that they
weren't there to apprehend us to take us
into into prison no
they were there they were there to
capture us hand us over with the
with with the cartels and the cartels
were gonna handle where this girl told
me that i was gonna get dismembered
brother these things don't have like i'd
be like man
what and like i couldn't understand you
know i like for me like
i would say like it's because we're
we're tough right
god is god is most merciful bro and
like just thinking about how how
everything was ending up
like knowing a month later that if like
it could have been easy for us to just
say we give up we give up right
if we if we would have given up they
wouldn't they weren't gonna put us
they weren't gonna take us to court they
weren't gonna turn us in
they were gonna give us up with with the
cartels because the cartels were already
going
like the car the rival cartel was going
with these cops
they were gonna they were gonna
dismember us there do you see how
allah has been taking me out of danger
taking me out of danger
and i was so ignorant and so so
fingering bro like i was ignorant i was
being dumb
by not recognizing that there was a
higher power in my life that
something was taking care of me like all
these all this activity going around me
about gin and everything
but he is he is over everything else
nothing was getting to me nothing
none of this this black magic none of
this none of these gents were actually
getting to me because he was always he
was always taking care of me taking care
of me taking care of me
and i wouldn't recognize that bro i
wouldn't i wouldn't recognize it i would
say no
it's just our luck you know this is
because we're we're trained
because we we we've been trained you
know you don't you don't just
you don't just go into a cartoon start
and start working without
without knowing your your business right
they're not just gonna give you're gonna
say oh go fight no
you have to be trained you have to know
how to how to fight these people
and it was like it was probably because
of that because we're good at what we do
it wasn't because of that it was because
allah almighty was taking care of me and
without me knowing it
and the most surprising thing bro like
the they would always tell me they were
always forced to tell my
my my my future i would always get that
people would tell me like no they did
this you're going to end up
getting killed and i and i would accept
it you know
i was like i'm here because i'm not
afraid of dying and i'm ready to die any
days
let's do it you know let's let's go but
the same cartel members that i was with
they would tell me
like hey because i was like i said i i
would carry my my amulet as well and and
we would carry a big uh holy death like
that right and wherever we would be
we would we would put it on the corner
and we would put it we would turn on uh
candles and we would deliver candy we
would put a beer we would put uh fruits
you know
and and my friends that we had more
involved that had
been more involved with with this would
tell me
hey don't don't ever let don't ever uh
how do you say this word in english
don't ever stop taking care of her
because if you stay
if you stop taking care of it's a it's a
piece of wood bro
it's a piece of it's nothing you know it
has no power
but that's the metallic they have that
if you stopped caring for her
that she she was going to play back on
you and she was going to get you back
it's crazy my brother jeez
bro okay my bad for interrupting you
because you're on a roll here
but um even though
you feel like you were ignorant during
that time i don't think that it was
true ignorance because just think about
this right like
if allah is giving us mercy if allah is
giving us
guidance it's so that we may
perhaps reflect on it and
allow ourselves to accept that guidance
because like how many people are
receiving guidance but they are they
just close off completely to it and it's
like
at some point another that guidance is
gonna be it's gonna stop it's gonna stop
coming in if you keep closing yourself
off to it
but it's like bro like i could sit back
and say like bro i was so ignorant back
then but it
it's not that i was fully ignorant it's
that i was just
i was astray i was astray it's like i
knew it deep down i knew
what was coming what was happening what
was like happening here but it's like i
didn't want to accept it
and i was astray and it wasn't until
like i started to
uh i guess you could say be in less
resistance to these things that i
started to open up and see it for what
it actually was
so yeah again bro i don't think it's i
don't think it's ignorance i think i was
like
i was i'll say i think i was angry to
the fact that there was a higher
being right at that moment and that i
didn't reflect on what was going on it
had it had to be like
i noticed this when i when i stepped out
of that life
and then when i started uh striving to
be a muslim
when i started looking at my life bro
like i would just like i would just sit
down right like i have nowhere to go
when i talk to them just sit down on my
bed
and just think about everything you
don't think about everything and and
that
everything would like i said everything
falls into perfect into a perfect puzzle
bro
because nothing is nothing is a
coincidence and and i would cry because
i would be like
i can't believe i can't believe i was i
was so astray
accepting these these um
[Music]
accepting the life that i was walking
because at the end you you're following
these gyms right you're doing their
dirty work because at the end that's
what you're doing
but you're you're following in that step
that you know that
that you're gonna end up wrong but you
don't turn your back on them you keep
walking towards them
and and you don't accept that that
there's a creator that there's something
else
that you're that's why i say that i was
angry on the way that i wasn't accepting
the things how they were
now that i i i'm a muslim like there's
no way brother that i'm gonna i'm gonna
step away from being a muslim because i
i
see i've seen with proof in my life
what allah has done in my life and how
he was he has kept me from danger
when everything was against me when i
knew that i was gonna die
and and the the scary part is that you i
wasn't afraid anymore bro like
but well i'm not right i know i'm on the
right path but in
in that moment i i knew i wasn't afraid
of dying even though
i didn't i wasn't sure i wasn't sure of
what was to come after death
but it's it's it's it's a way it's a
wake-up call bro like
it's like every time i think about it
like man i just wanna
i just wanna sit down and just praise my
creator because it's amazing bro like
like i'm lucky man i'm lucky just like
just to tell you about all my friends
how they ended up
how how they how they've been
i'm gonna tell you something right so i
had a friend
his his nickname was rocky right he was
the same the same height as me
we were like we were like two drops of
water bro and we had worked in the house
and this brother was he was a straight
up gangster bro he was
not afraid of doing anything now look he
he went
he he we went on on a mission right
and we broke into this home we're gonna
do some stuff
but this home was protected by the same
you understand
this home was protected by the same we
go in
we get into a gunfight nothing happens
but
we ran out of bullets and we try to walk
well i i ran out first
and then rocky round behind me and he
literally told me that he felt that
something
grabbed them something grabbed them and
he couldn't move like he couldn't step
he couldn't like he couldn't keep moving
you know that something just suppressed
him like that outside the outside the
door of these people
when we went in like they had a bunch of
um
a bunch of these these saints right and
they had devils because like
when you worship the holy death you you
worship the devil as well like
you know that the devil is real and the
demo has certain power
to give you you know that he gives you
things
and like what he did was like he because
he was a really believer in the same
and he grabbed on to who he could to his
saints supposedly
and then when he grabbed it like he
started feeling that he he had
he had strength again and he started
running like he just
barely killed me like we were about to
we were about to drive off when he just
jumped like through the window you know
and then they kept shooting at us we
went into
i went into prison first and then he got
caught up inside a prison we were
talking you know
we just have strange conversations and
and and like we will talk about this you
know
the the the experiences that we've had
with jinns and and
not jesus but the the uh we thought it
was like the
the um demonic experiences with with
these with these
beings that were that were protecting us
because at the end you know what you're
in there you know
you you know that you're you're you're
an evil person
and you're in and and you following it
following these steps of these
of of these jins is going to lead you to
to a very
dark place the funny part is that
he told me he's like he had the same he
he was there for murder right
the same thing happened with him that
happened with me we had a witness but uh
yeah a protective witness he had a dream
bro
and like a week before he went into his
final court and he told me he's like
i had a dream he he was very
excited because his his uh his witness
had had escaped his witness had escaped
so so the government didn't have his
witness he was really happy because he
he thought he was gonna leave
now look at the funny part he's like i
had a dream i was like what was that bro
he's like i i was dreaming that i i got
into a truck with with the people that
we used to write
and that we left you behind bro that you
that you were building a wall
i was like what are you talking about
man he's like yeah it was strange like
he's like don't don't feel bad but i
think i think you you might stay here
i was like brother come on man like why
am i gonna feel bad if i know what i'm
doing like we know we accept the
consequences even if
if i have to stay here i was like i was
getting ready my mentality wasn't like
i'm gonna get my freedom my mentality
was i'm gonna stay here and i need to
see how to survive here
when when um when roger told me this
he's like
when i leave i'm not gonna forget about
you i'm gonna come back
even if i have to break into prison i'm
going to take you out
thanks bro because we were really close
right he's really close brother
um bro he went to his final court date
a day at night before like
it was gonna be like let's say it was on
friday on thursday at night
they caught this person they caught his
witness so
when he went to court bro he came back
crying brother
he came back crying he's like they gave
me 20 years
they gave me 20 years and he couldn't
believe it he couldn't believe it
you know but did you see do you see how
his dream had
he was dreaming he was gonna he was
rolling in a truck and that i was i was
staying building a wall
he was thinking that i was gonna stay
and he was gonna leave
and at the end he was the one that
stayed bro and and and he was
like he would still be closed like he
was crying but he would always he would
always say like
i i know that my saint my saints going
to get me out of here he would kiss him
he would kiss and he would kiss it while
he was crying bro
yeah i am at the end of the day like i
i did have my saints and everything but
my my faith wasn't 100 towards
you know i did i was like you know what
whatever has to happen is going to
happen
i'm not going to blame or i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna ask for any special favors
whatever's gonna happen is gonna happen
i wasn't totally into
i wasn't in a specific form but my
belief in it wasn't
like his because even even him seeing
that he was left in prison for 20
for 20 years like he was crying in his
being in his bed and he was kissing it
kissing it
and he would tell me he's like i'm not
going to stay here i'm not like
bro this is a hardcore criminal crying
and kissing him
kissing this type of you you know how
the jins were laughing at him that when
he was doing that bro
like they were making fun of my my uh my
god
like and then that this is this is what
what these gyms do
you know they get to this point where
they make fun of you because
of the of the stupidity that you're
doing because bro this
my my brother was a hardcore criminal
and and he was crying on his bed
kissing it and kissing and kissing and
saying my saints gonna get me out of
here my saints gonna get me
when you see these rokia videos like
exorcism right they literally
sometimes they record the gin and like
what they're saying right
and a lot of the time bro they're just
straight out laughing
it's crazy bro crazy like
crazy brother and it's like i said
i'm working on a book right now right
this book is this book is not like i'm
gonna write on
like the person that's helping to write
it he's gonna write it like a third
person
um it's gonna be
based on true events but 95
90 like ninety nine percent of it is
true bro
you guys aren't gonna believe the things
that i've seen bro like damn like you
like that's why i feel i feel really
strong in my deen you know like i feel
really strong
at the end of the day i know that i'm on
the right path because not not because
what i've heard
not because of what what anybody has
told me about what i've experienced in
my life
and and the mercy that i see that i see
that is is from
my lord you know bro as soon as that
book is ready bro
we'll promote it on the channel bro but
before we end up this one though tell us
tell us a few more
what crazy jin stories have you had in
your life directly
after converting to islam when you feel
like you're trying to get closer to
allah
you mentioned one which was uh when you
were trying to wake up for fajr and then
you had that gin on top of you right so
i woke i woke up for fudger and i did my
prayer
and then i i i when i slept on my bed
and while i was watching the video like
it just came on top of me
[Music]
um
nah bro i i've had i haven't had that
much experience with jensen in that way
but then the way like in in the actual
like you say you're feeling them
but um hearing them yeah i'm
to the day you know like like sometimes
like i feel i feel how i'm getting
pressured you know from the back like
i feel like my my neck like if someone
was like
sitting on me and when i would pray like
i'm talking about like five months ago
like i would pray bro and i would feel
these these genes behind me right
brother i'm like i said i'm i'm i don't
have knowledge bro
so i was trying to do what i what i
would what i would be what i would
what i would understand right but i
would feel these
these descended these entities behind me
and and
they would they would they would uh come
in and start
poisoning my mind because that's what
that's what happens they want they want
to get you
they they don't want you to concentrate
on on what you're doing
now i know the things that you're
supposed to do for to get that away
but i did it and that's what that's the
way i was getting like
that's the way that's the only that's
the only way i would see them and i
would feel them
i i didn't tell you guys but i had this
strange
capability like the the brother i got
that brother that they shot down
remember i was talking about that the
the the homeboy the one that they killed
in front of his family
a month before this happened um
i was talking to him and and i could
literally see him and i would see him
dead but
i don't know how to explain this but i
was seeing him and i was seeing him
his his his features his facial features
i knew he was going to die and i told
him like hey
be careful come on like i see that that
there's problems here
and he's like nah i'll be okay the day
that they killed them i was coming down
from from doing some stuff and i called
him and i'm like hey
i don't really want to go to the party
like let me kick it at your house
right we'll just smoke something you
know i'll kick it with you know it was
just me and him
and he's like nah like go to the party
have some fun you're like don't come
here because it's really hot but when he
says it's really hot it's like there's a
lot of there's a lot of
uh uh popo you know there's a lot of
police
uh he's like it's very hard i was coming
halfway and i called him again i'm like
hey
i don't i don't want to be there bro i
don't know i want to spend the day with
you
like come on man i'm i'm i'm i have
these days off
let me spend let me spend it with you
like you know i'm not i'm not that type
of person
i wasn't really the type of person at
parties and i'm telling my let me let me
kick you with you homie
and he's like nah man i told you to go
to the party
bro i was driving by his house and i
called him again i'm like hey let me let
me stay in your house bro
let me stay there let me stay with you
i'll kick you with you we don't need to
do anything special
it's just let me just kick it with you
he's like nah like there's some there's
the cops keep passing the cops keep
passing and i told him like hey
i i'm strapped bro i'm strapped and
and i have i have i have something to
protect myself from
i was like nah man go to the party
bro i got to the party not two minutes
passed his
his wife called me crying they got down
and they they gunned them down they cut
them down
and uh at the back of on the phone
i could hear my brother went they shot
him 17 times in the back bro
i was like that was my camera
where were the police the police shot
him 17 times
another cartel they came and they they
started
they started just having a discussion
about where was i
you know they were asking him like where
was i like
they wanted him to to tell to tell them
like because i was i was already working
for another cartel
but i wasn't working on that song but
these people had got information that i
was working there when i wasn't
so they were basically like they were
hunting me down right
and when i get that call like they
well i i've never like i've never cried
for a lot of a lot of my karma's i've
gone because we know that we're in the
life
but for that coming like it broke my
heart bro
i i got to the i got like um like two
blocks away from his house and
i couldn't get close because of of of
the uh the police that were picking up
his body
and i knew i knew where everything was
coming from right because
we had an incident that had that that
led up to this to this
point and i just felt that something
came over me bro
come here came over me you know i
grabbed my pistol and
i went to this guy's house bro i snuck
into his house and i was outside his
window and i was seeing him inside
he was laying down with his wife and his
two kids bro
like i was like this to go in and just
take care of everything of everything
bro what i mean everything everything
brother
but i just started breaking down i just
started crying i just started crying and
i told myself this is not me this isn't
me you know
but like those things are always like
they always come they always like
take the best of you know in that moment
i thought that's like
now that i think of it i was like why
would you do something like that you
know
but when i felt that when i felt that
vibe coming to me
i just went and i broke it to this guy's
house and i was ready to do to handle
business bro and
at the end i just broke i just broke and
i was like man
i can't i can't do this i just and i
just left and
the friends that were waiting for me
because there was there was a car
waiting for me outside
to drive off like when i went back
they're like what happened like why
should why did you take care of business
i was like let's go let's just go
let's go i left a couple of days passed
and we started taking care of business
of the people that have done this to my
brother
look how look how how god is now this
one this is another example that i tell
you guys like
he has been taking care of me and you
have no idea
[Music]
i well you when you're working for a
cartel you you have a safe house right
you always have a safe house where you
can where you can
you can get there and like your you just
chilled it right
we had it we were working in a different
city and in this city we we ended up
doing our business
but the car breaks down i don't know
where bro the car breaks down
it doesn't want to turn on anymore
and i told i told my homeboy we have to
go back to
we have to get back down there like we
have to go look for the people that
killed my brother
and he's like but how we can like we
didn't want to steal a car we didn't we
just want
we that's why we were using that one i'm
like let's get it fixed and let's go
bro like the mechanics would come they
would fix it we would turn it on drive a
little bit it would break down again
and i was like i was getting mad bro
it's like man i
i really cuz i was my the hate that i
had in me
was get these people get these people
that are taking that that had done this
to my brother
bro i'm not i'm not kidding the person
that i ended up
with prison remember i was telling you
guys there was two other people with me
um that did i was i was supposed look
how things are bro
it was me the a friend of mine and his
cousin
we were supposed to kill him right we
told his cousin that like
my friend told me hey if you're going to
handle business with him don't do it in
my house
i was like nah man we're going to take
him allah saved him from that day
because that day we were going to kill
him right
inside of prison he's like he's like you
got lucky
i was like why because those
there was two specific days he said
these people were waiting for you there
was more than 20 people waiting
for you for for your team to get to get
to that safe house
bro they slept there brother waiting for
me
outside of the house ready for for the
car to pull up and they were going to
blast us they were going to take us
and he's like and i was there with them
he told me this like five months in
prison
he five months five months into prison
he confessed because he wouldn't confess
like
inside a prison like i would i would
punk him around you know
just like try to interrogate him get any
information i could from him
i was like you were working for these
people now i wasn't working for anybody
at the end he confessed everything bro
he's like yeah like these people were
there and this and that and he's like
you know what there was two days
where you guys we knew where you guys
were staying we knew where your safe
house was
he's like and we were looking for him we
were just waiting for you to get there
we were there it was two cars
filled with people they were ready to
kill you so you got lucky
he's like you got lucky man because if
you if this if you weren't here you said
you would have been dead
and at the moment i was like i didn't
understand
but then they hit me i was like wait
those two days was when the car broke
down
and i was supposed to go back to that
security house
alhamdulillah brother allah's the
greatest when i say i mean it brother
that's why it's hard bro like
i try not to get to get emotional bro
there's
there's no reason i can't you know
because
[Music]
allah has been very merciful to me
that's why
i can't i can't just sit around and say
look i'm not going to do anything about
it
if i know that i used to influence these
people if i used to
be the poison now that allah has guided
me to something real i'm i'm gonna
i'm gonna try to fight the fight in a
different way right i'm not saying i'm
gonna fight them
like i used to but fight fight
a war that is is not in this not of
of of this nature you know well you were
ready to die for the wrong cause so now
you
you're trying to die for the right cause
brother that that's my dream
it's not my dream you know may allah's
will happen but
like i said that was that was my dream
bro
that was like my dream my dream was to
die in the cartels like i would hear
songs dedicated to these people that
would kill themselves
of being of being a very um
courageous people in in my head i was
like that's how i'm gonna go
if i'm gonna if i have to go i'm gonna
go like this this that's what i'm gonna
tell you guys
but this is the one that really really
impacted me
we got to a certain place right and
we're gonna get to a brand new bmws
we're about to get them wrong they they
get off and then they start getting off
the people right
the the homeboys that got off to try not
to to drive off with the bmws
like they couldn't move them uh two of
the these were very important people
um their bodyguards came out and they
started shooting at us
and we got into a small gunfight but
we ended up leaving the bmws and they
got into the car and we drove off
out of nowhere bro uh f-150 rammed us
from the back
we like the it rammed us we were in a
small car and they rammed us
and they started shooting bro literally
i felt like
five bullets went in my back i felt
really hot like this part really hot
and one of the bullets i came like i was
in the middle
there was a driver the co-pilot and my
two friends right here and i was in the
middle
bro when i started hearing the shots and
the the window shattered like
i felt the bullet bro like i had a i had
a burn from the bullet
like the powder it was like it just it
just scratched me bro
and the uh the where you rest your head
it hit that and it bounced off to the um
to the stereo
[Music]
the only thing i did was like i turned
like i like it's when everybody was just
like panicking like i just remember i
pulled my rifle
and i turned around and it stuck it out
the window and i started blasting bro
like i just let
i end up hitting the computer in the car
the the f-150 i
end up hitting the the computer and it
just stopped right
when we were going like everybody was
like we were panicking
because like the car had been shot up
like you know
you have no idea how how many bullets
went into this car
i was i was trying i was trying to take
off my vest because i was telling my
brother hey
i got shot man i got shot he's like why
is it i feel hot i feel
like i i feel like warm like something's
and he's like
well i felt the pain bro like i would
feel the pain in the back of my in the
back of my
on the back of me and he's like let me
see let me see and i pulled it up he's
like ah
you don't and he's like he's like i
swear i saw you guys
get shot in the head i was like man it
was close
we get off we get to a safe location we
get off and and
we pull up we push up the trunk right
where i was sitting bro
the there was an amplifier and the
amplifier had all the shots bro
i was sitting where the amplifier was i
see how close my life was like
i felt i felt really hot because of the
blast that hit the amplifier
but all the bullets were on the
amplifier and the amplifier was on the
back of the seat like i was sitting on
the seat like that
and i got hit on the back but without
without actually trust like
without actually passing and the brother
brothers like
that's when he told me like you know you
know that the the the holy the holy
death just takes care of you for a
little while right
and then it's it comes for you i was
like
we're ready to die man because i was
ready bro i was ready and
like i would see like all these
situations where i would see my life
getting taken away like in a blast like
nothing happened though nothing but i
was like
like man now that i'm here i i just look
at my life and be like
what what was i involved in like to what
extent was i ready to die for these
people
because at the end that's what you do
you you're ready to die with people that
have
and you go with these cartels these
cartel leaders bro like you find trines
dedicated to these to these gins bro
like shrines and and and what they do
with what the
with with the the rival cartels
like they'll skin them alive and they'll
put body parts on on
like around this around this this gin
that's how demonic these these people
are
probably that's why i
i was like at the end of the at the end
of my ride with the cartels
i would think to myself oh my god yeah
i'm certain there's evil
i'm 100 sure that evil exists that the
devil exists that all these
demons exist because i've seen it
firsthand i've seen how they work
there there has to be something there
has to be a good in this world there has
to be something that is right
i couldn't find that i couldn't find an
explanation to it right like i was
i was i was lost but like seeing to what
extent these people
these people do like i had some i had
some brothers i worked for a different
cartel right
not the one that i just left but i
worked for a different cartel
bro these people would take out the
heart and then they would they would
squirt it in a tequila shop
they would squirt it they would they
would get the heart bumpy and they would
put they would pour out the blood
into the little into the little cup and
they'd be like hey
drink it say once you drink it you're
going to feel like you're you're going
to feel like you're you're 10 minutes
strong
like that bro i'm going to say if i
drink it and
i don't want to say that but bro just
imagine to what
mentality these people were in like how
like how lost was i how lost was i
brother
to be involved in in in in this
in this environment like
man there's there's there's few words to
explain it you know
only only allah is is the one that was
taking care of me he's the only one that
has
guided you to this but it was because at
the end i let everything go
you know i let everything go because i
knew that i by myself i couldn't get
nowhere
by myself i couldn't find peace because
i couldn't even though
i i in in in in the cartel like
i wouldn't i wouldn't even sleep like i
would have to i would have to have a car
sleeping right next not sleeping but
sitting right next to me and me sitting
like me sleeping in in in his feet you
know
and him with the rifle i just that's how
that's how panicked we were from
from other cartel members like just be
careful and
not because like that's how much how
much um
this loyalty is in the cartel like
you'll get killed you'll get ambushed by
the same cartel just take your position
so i couldn't even sleep i didn't have
peace in me and
and i and i was i would think to myself
like am i gonna die for these people
like is is my life worth dying for these
like it's
like i know like that you're a warrior
but
look at the cost that you're gonna die
for like look
at what you're doing look at looking at
how you're destroying society like all
those games like not not those games but
all the all the reality that was going
on
because you can be in the cartoon and
say i'm fighting for the right cause
i'm doing this because i'm tired of
being poor i'm doing this because i
wanna i wanna be rich i wanna be famous
be real with yourself and know what
you're doing and i was being real with
myself
i think that's why allah started having
more mercy and he's like okay
now i'm gonna guide you towards real
because i started being real with myself
bro
i started thinking to myself like am i
ready to die for these people these
people are trash
these people are poisoning the young
minds because i would see people i
would see young young youngsters you
know youngsters get killed like
youngsters would jump into the military
into the uh into the cartel
and they would get killed by the
military by the police
youngsters bro youngsters i'm talking
about like 13 year olds
13 year olds bro 14 year olds like get
killed bro
you see a little kid like they're little
kids man you know
like this there's a saying in in in in
spanish like they don't even got
pubic hairs bro and
they're and they get killed and just
seeing like their bodies
we had a close friend he was uh
we call it basic he was going
he was just he would just manage radios
this kid was like 12. he would manage
radios and he would he would he would
pass codes because everything is in
codes there
he got killed by he got killed by the
cops
and and and the cops went to it he got
turned into
his his his family they gave they gave
the kid up to his family with the with
the shot in the back and they told him
that the kid tried to shoot him
you know how much hate we got towards
them because the kid never the kid
didn't carry guns
that wasn't his job and and and it was
like
me being at the funeral and looking at
the little kid with a little kitty
he would always he would always mess
around with this he's like come on man
i want to go with you guys i want to
roll with you guys yeah i want i want to
put on i want to put on the pachetta i
want to carry the ar i want to carry the
the
ak-47 you know i want to go to war with
you and i will i would just go like
come on man you're too small look how he
died bro
for for forgiving for giving them the
bad example for giving them
the wrong reasons to to to live for and
it's
it's sad it breaks my heart to see all
these kids like
throwing their life away because at the
end like their kids bro like
they haven't had a right guidance you
know from their fathers or
ha they haven't had those good examples
and it's just truly cerebral it's truly
sad how
how our our children are dying here
bro most kids end up as a statistic bro
it's the harsh reality but that's what
it is right and uh
i wanted to touch on a point that you
mentioned before that you were saying
that it's
it's sad to see where you used to be
right or other people might say it's sad
to see where we used to be in life
or whatever right here's the thing bro
shaytan works in steps
so in like looking back now and and you
know
looking back and reflecting about where
we were we're not going to understand
how
how we how did we get here what had to
go down for us to get to this low point
rock bottom but shaytan doesn't put you
there overnight april
if shaytan put you there overnight
instantaneously bro you'd be like why am
i here
you didn't you'd instantly be like okay
you know shaytan knows how to work with
the human mind that you need to go
slowly you know one percent two percent
three percent
and then over a year over ten years then
you get to a point you're not even in
question anymore
because the changes were so slow and
subtle that you your your mind wouldn't
even comprehend what's happening to you
before you know it you gotta you got
that shot of of blood
the tequila shot just ready and you're
gonna you're not even gonna question
anymore
but if i just put that into a kid's hand
they're gonna throw it away they're
gonna think what's happening why would i
hold that
right
that's why it's it's necessary brother
to to
to spread islam you know just to just to
put the seed because at the end of the
day there's
there's there's i've met carlos are my
brothers that have been in that criminal
life and
they they understand what they're doing
and they understand that
that there is something out there that
is better than the life that we chose
because at the end
we don't we don't fake it you know we
don't we don't say like um
[Music]
like you can't you can't do that when
you're when you're in that life you
can't say
i i regret everything i did
if you're a hardcore criminal you're
gonna regret anything because you know
that there's consequences for everything
you do
so like these people some of them like
they get to rock bottom
but there's no one there to tell them
hey you know what islam is the way
allah has mercy on you that's what
there's a reason why you're still alive
and there's a reason why a lot of these
these carnalists are still alive
at these ages that they've been in
prison for them for the
for a long time these these brothers
that that are out there you know
and i said to myself like i'm gonna i
ain't gonna stop until i get i get i get
them out of there
or or not not me because i can't do
anything right
but i ain't gonna stop until i i i i
plant that seed in their heart for them
to turn around and look at their creator
the way i looked at it
the way i turned around and gave up
everything i had and just fled
i submitted to him bro there's nothing
in this there's nothing i have that
bothers me today
like alhamdulillah i'm blessed and i'm
happy and i'm always like
i'm laughing and i just think of the
things that had happened like talking to
other people
like i talked to some of them some of
the commanders and they were like
because like they were they're in a bad
position inside prison
and i was like you guys are you guys are
there because you guys are criminals
but i'm just making fun of them you know
just like just joking around with it
i'm like that's why you guys are there
because you guys are a bunch of
criminals and they're like shut up
it's like you would be here as well
you'd be here with us i'm like
you're right but i lost the most
merciful and i'm here i'm standing out
here
i'm standing out here looking at you
guys and not forgetting about you guys
so you guys better be grateful with god
and they're like
all right bro he said we appreciate we
appreciate what you're doing you know
because i
i've told them like you guys i'm not
gonna give up i'm not gonna say you know
what
i'm free i'm gonna turn my back on you
guys
i know what it feels to be in there and
i also know what it feels to be in the
cartels
and how they use you and how your life
goes thrown in the trash
like there's people like me that need to
that you speak out
i know that there's more people like me
i'm not the only one there's there's a
lot more that have been through a lot a
lot worse than me
and and and and they need to speak out
you know i always said like i'm not
gonna say anything
i'm just gonna keep everything quiet i'm
just gonna i'm just gonna stay quiet
about everything and i'm just gonna keep
keep doing my stuff but bro like if we
don't speak out who else is gonna speak
out you know
who else is gonna say you know what it's
wrong and i see this in like
in you know in the community you know
they bro they look up to these people
like if they were heroes brother
and and it's wrong like
one that has been in that knows what the
reality is they're just like in an
illusion
uh fantasizing with something that is
never going to happen
it's it's broke and then when we see
that in the rap role
i'm talking about also like the in in
the us you know
you see all you see all these kids
thinking they're gangsters thinking that
they're
that that come on man it's a fantasy
that they're living in
and they forget that we're gonna die
they forget that this world is just
temporary
alhamdulillah i'm blessed for for not
for for having that
that knowledge that i'm gonna die i'm
always thinking about that
i have to a wise person thinks about
death
like a smart person thinks about death a
wise person gets ready for death bro
he's getting right i'm getting ready you
know it doesn't matter if i'm gonna die
here in 10 20 years
but that that step of you taking care of
your afterlife
being being conscious of that this world
is going to pass and we're going to die
alhamdulillah i've had that you know i
have that
really really deep inside my heart
because i was ready to die before
for all the wrong reasons like you just
said but now that i'm a muslim
like i'm striving and i'm ready you know
i'm getting ready for that afterlife i'm
getting it so that's why
like talking to a brother from san diego
i told him i'm like
the reason i'm the reason that i'm
talking to you know like
yeah i could tell you i put in a lot of
work
i earned my respects inside the prison
i've earned my respects in the industry
but brother i was a fool i was a bum
i was doing i was putting in work for
the wrong reasons now that i'm in islam
now that i'm on the straight path and
allah is guiding me i'm gonna put in
some heavy work for it too you know
i'm i'm gonna i'm working for my
afterlife i'm not working for info
this life has no meaning for me yeah
this life has no value this dunya is
nothing for me
i i want to put in work for my afterlife
not for anybody else for me for my
afterlife for
for what's what's coming for me because
i know that i'm going to die and i'm
going to die alone
you know and and telling this to this
brother because like
he this brother was asking me like
because he was like he was just trying
to like chat with me like a normal like
a normal like a normal person i was like
bro
i'm not a normal person and and i'm also
not thinking like a normal person now
i'm thinking like
someone that has is has come out of
those places with a different mentality
[Music]
i'm i'm trying to put in hard work and
i'm trying to put in work to
make a change a lot of people say like
you come on man just
you're trying to act like a saint now
it's not it's not we're not we're
nobody's the same
we all have defects and we all have
shortcomings alhamdulillah
loves the ones that were bad you know
the ones that go back to him every time
we fail but it's not like that that
beautiful feeling that when you're
praying you put your head down and
asking
for allah's forgiveness i'm stuck for
allah every time brother every time i do
something wrong
i just remember you know like he's the
one that has put me here
so there's a reason why i'm here and and
i know that this is
this isn't going to stop and we saw the
other day right with the with the power
was
was going out brother it hasn't gone out
since you know
it's it's it's just like
where i'm at and how much these gins
are hating what we're doing and i've
talked to brothers here
um not too far away but they also
they're helping me with this plan
they're they're they're getting people
of knowledge that have been in
in in medina that have studied medina
that speaks spanish that are going to be
able to
to get this message and and and give
dawah to these people
and they're telling me like hey like
what's going on with dudes
believe me it's going out with is going
on with us too because
the jinns don't want us here this is
their land this is the land of the dead
you know like in tj you tijuana is the
only place
where there's a christian church in the
middle of two um
two strip clubs bro just imagine how
how how messed up society is right now
that there is a church in the middle of
two strip clubs
that's mexico imagine that bro
so he they were telling me that hey this
is it's not new they were helping me out
with some
with some presentations for protection
and everything and they're like
we know what you're talking about
because we have
we have personally encountered this
they don't want to let they don't want
to let go of this of this of this
country
believe me and if we have to give a
fight we're going to give a fight we
ain't afraid of anything you know
alhamdulillah he's he's given us he's
given us courage you know
he's he's made he's made us brave
because
you can be a muslim and be afraid you
know don't be afraid of what
what they might think about me they're
going to call me a terrorist so they're
going to do this
you you always try to hide your religion
i come to you every time i get on a car
out there i'll tell them i'm a muslim
and i'll start giving dollars to them
the way i can you know and just just
trying to
just trying to do that you know trying
to try to trying to uh
spread the message you know tell them
that no we have to turn back to our lord
and our lord there's only one
brother
bro first thing i want to say bro is man
that's why we got to support you bro
everyone watching this right now
link in the description down below to
support zach's dollar project which
right after we're done before we wrap it
up he's going to go a little bit in
depth into because
a lot of people this is your first
episode that they're seeing they didn't
see part one
so actually first thing guys if you
haven't seen part one what are you doing
bro go see part one
this is part two second thing i wanted
to ask rami something so rami this is
your first
episode with zach right so am i tripping
or like
as a born muslim as someone like the
viewers think you know we do this for
them
but as the host we're getting so much
value and such an iman boost from zach
you agree or not one hundred percent man
masha allah bro i was just
i was just thinking i was just thinking
there's
so much value we can take from a brother
like this who has experienced
everything he experienced who is now
coming to islam bro allah
like everything from from the experience
he has to the characteristics he has now
and his mentality
bro like i feel like honestly i feel
like a baby
i feel like a baby in my islam when it
comes to when it comes to the brother
here because he seems to be so like
just brought that yaki in that certainty
masha allah and that
that that certainty that he's going to
work for the dean
i looking at him i feel like i'm lacking
honestly so may allah bless him
immensely brother honestly
masha allah brother i know when i'm i'm
alhamdulillah man i keep be humble you
know at the end of the day i know that
i'm i'm
nothing bro but if i can do a little bit
if i can help in any way i'm going to
try to do it because i've done a lot of
harm
you know and there's a saying that in
order for you to reach the skies
your your roots in order for a tree to
grow strong your roots have to reach
hell bro they have to they have to be
well
in my case that's what had happened i
had to be there
and see what that life is about in order
for me to grow strong because like now
i'm strong because of that
like nobody's going to come put fear of
me nobody's going to come and tell me
well don't do this because
get you get your little kids getting out
of here because i'm i'm ready to die for
my religion i'm ready to die from for
first time know
from what i believe because i'm i'm
certain now and like that's why i say
just looking at my life and going like
going back and looking at everything
every small situation that i've had
that i've been close to dying scares me
the way that that the person that i was
back there
was not afraid of dying and was 100
willing to leave its life
in in in in trash in the most worst
ways that a human being can die i was
willing to do that
for all the wrong reasons and now that
i'm in i'm in islam
and i understand there's a reason why
there's a reason why
why i came out of this world being a
mexican
you know being a cartel member like
bro there's all these cartel members
like i would think i
would look at myself and like just
compare myself with them
bro like they're so involved in like
they're so much their their love is so
much towards their cartel towards their
to towards their boss you know they're
the loyalty and the love and this and
that
i'm real i'm real and that's why i
understand like that's why i went to
prison
to to see the reality of of this game
that they're
this is this is nothing you know and
it's
it's a trick that shaytan plays on on
these youngsters
these youngsters that are out there that
are hearing me and that they wanna
they wanna feel hard you know like man
i've seen brothers come out i've seen
brothers grown
criminal brothers crying in prison just
just to know the sadness that they're
going to stay there for the rest of your
life if you're hearing me out there
you're thinking of
of hanging out with the wrong crowd
you guys don't know and i hope you guys
don't like me a lot
guys you guys may allah take you guys
from that path but
out of 10 people that go into that path
one and a half come out i'm not one and
a half that special
that's that special person that allah
had mercy upon because i've seen so many
brothers that are still there
that most of them are or have fallen in
in this
this in this uh this path that i was
taking you know
taking to to to a world that is not
there's nothing good out of it bro
that's that's why my
that's why i feel like this you know
brother and
like i'm thinking of actually like when
when this project when we get this
running
when we where we get the the opportunity
to see
to to sit 150 to sit 250
inmates i'm going to go and talk to them
you know like not talk to them but just
tell them
do you guys remember me do you guys
remember me when i was here i was like
who was i back then
who was i back then because i could bet
you brother i could put money onto that
everybody that you talked to that asked
him who was that uh he was a warrior he
was ready to die
i was ready to die bro i was very dying
i would tell my
brother the day that the the prison
found out that i was supposedly dead
when i told you that my mom found out
that i was there
everybody would say yeah that zack
just imagine how much these people knew
my character
that i was ready to die and i was and i
was a real warrior in that aspect
like everybody didn't everybody didn't
doubt themselves
they never doubted themselves that i was
gonna die in that game
because when i was in prison i stood up
firm you know and i was ready to die to
protect myself to protect the people
that were that were getting oppressed
and they
they had that respect towards me and for
them to for them to see me
back then like back there trying to do
that trying to trying to
to get this message and trying to help
them out if it's any mom booster for you
guys imagine them
like imagine them just thinking to
themselves like man
because like i'm like i said like uh
it's not too bad bro cause i have
nothing to brag about
i was i was a bum like i said before
like they're going to see
a person that was that that left prison
the way he said he was going to leave
how he got into the cartels and he still
he still grew in the cartels and
and and to just come back humble humble
and to say you guys you guys you guys
know why i'm doing this i'm doing this
because of you guys because i know what
it feels like to be here
and and i hope that you guys can take a
little bit of advantage of what we're
trying to do
that that's even and i know a lot of
people are gonna
are gonna respect me and a lot of people
respect me that way that they say
it takes a real man to change man i
spoke to one of my closest brothers in
prison
and he because i was telling him i was
giving him the message i was like hey
turn back on your creator bro like don't
worry because he has a he has a 20 a 20
year sentence right he's been there for
seven years
and he was like he's like man i'm just
i'm just losing it in here man i don't
know if i can if i can uh
hold on if i i don't know if i could if
i could take so many years
and i was telling him like you know what
you know who's in control of everything
allah is if you submit to him if you put
your trust in him
he's the one that's going to make
everything happen in your life but that
you want him brother
and you want it and he was like you're
right
and he and then he's like you know
what's funny i was like what
he's like brother like if you would have
told me this a year and a half ago
like you're you're he's like it takes a
real man to change
like that drastically like imagine like
i'm talking about a real hardcore
gangster saying
it takes a real man to change drastic
because you've changed
360 like you've come you've come you've
come
you've been you're a new person bro the
way you talk the way you
you remember us because he's like nobody
remembers about us like nobody cares
about the people that are in prison
nobody thinks about the people that are
that are lagging in there and
and the way that you're trying to help
us the way that you're trying to that
you're trying to bring this message
and the way that you're trying to keep
us alive in here like
i got some bad respect for you i'm like
brother don't
don't say that bro all right don't say
that
give thanks to god because i'm here and
and and i'm trying and i'm trying to do
my best for myself
down below turn back to allah if you
made it this far
um if the other two brothers have
anything jump in right now
otherwise bro in two minutes because i
know people have short attention spans
we're trying to wrap it up
quickly give the summary of what your
project is
for anyone that wants to donate and they
want to know what's the cause
the project itself is to be able to
provide with with literature with with
actual
islamic books in spanish hardcover books
not a book that we're going to give to
them and they're going to throw it in
the trash where it's going to give no
hard cover
books that they're going to be able to
keep and that they're going to be able
to use you know
um basically this is this is the way
that we're going to do it we're going to
be organizing events
in these prisons speaking to the to the
to the to the people inside
the the social workers that work inside
of prison and and and share the idea
that we wanted we want to go inside not
just to give them a book
not just to to to share with them the
message that we have that is more
valuable than anything else we can give
them
but what you guys are going to do
basically you guys are going to give
them a shampoo
a body spray lotion uh
like we're going to give them packages
of of things that they're going to be
able to use
every single day that they're going to
like it's going to be meant for them and
then we're gonna let them know you know
we're giving you this message but we're
also giving you this that has value
that the muslim community is worrying
about you guys that the muslim community
wants you guys to find the real path the
straight path
the only path that there is bro there
you know there ain't no other way
like they can they can probably tell you
that there's other way there's no other
way but
but just meant to allow the most high
that's all
um and like muslims like this money
is not being touched it's not gonna be
touched until everything is concrete
everything is everything is ready to go
so
if you guys are saying no well he's
going to probably use it brothers a lot
of my witness i'm not going to touch
that until we don't have something
concrete and we're able to send someone
with knowledge because
like i said before we have to do this
with a lot of intelligence we have to
put we have to put
a lot of effort what you guys are doing
like
you guys don't know how many people you
guys are going to help alhamdulillah for
the people that have
that have done this that in their hearts
that they want to they wanna support us
you guys don't actually even if it's the
minimum here in mexico
it's three times where you guys are
putting so
may allah bless you guys and like just
so you guys can have an idea you guys
are gonna provide
with something valuable but even more
valuable we're going to provide them
with
with hard book cut with with heart with
uh hardcore hardcover books
uh islamic literature like quran and and
other books that they can reflect
themselves in you know
that they can actually they can actually
see that we're not gonna give them
a normal piece of paper like christians
chris is going to give him a paper here
i'm gonna give you a flyer
no i'm gonna give you a hardcover book
that has value to it you're not gonna be
able to get rid of this book
you're gonna put it in you're gonna put
it up there and something of the message
that you heard
is going to make you read that book you
understand that they're going to they're
not going to be able to
to just say oh this isn't just a piece
of paper and through it no
it's going to be a hardcover hardcover
books for those people that really want
knowledge
because you know that islam is about
knowledge this is real knowledge
it's knowledge that you can read and you
can understand because that's what it is
it's the word of allah like i've read
the bible so many times brother inside
of prison like we've got like
we don't well they don't even know what
they're reading like i've seen
i've seen brothers smoke they'd rather
smoke the bible than read it bro
but when there is when there is
something right there's something
straight
like they're going to read it and
they're going to fall in love with the
literature they're going to fall in love
with with the words of my creed so
that's what basically what you guys are
doing
and and what you guys know that this
that
it takes money to do everything you know
we want to make this like the project
is right now in three three prisons
two small dis district uh district
prisons that are about uh
four to six hundred inmates we wanna sit
down 200
in each in each uh event from 100 to
200.
sit down people we're not even going to
tell them what we're going to give them
we're just going to we're going to
invite them
and if they say if they sit down and
they hear the message then we're going
to give them these
these products we're not just going to
give everybody no no we want people that
really want to that really want
something
that really that are really in that
search of finding truth
uh these are just two of them the major
one is we want to sit down at like
probably like a thousand a thousand
inmates but the two the
first that we're going to start with is
is these two small district
prisons that i have specifically been in
and i know people in there
and we know that we can we can make this
project happen you know we can we can
make these events happen where
we're actually doing something for our
community you know we're gonna the
muslim community here in mexico is gonna
represent
inside you know alhamdulillah may allah
bless you guys if you guys are looking
at this video and you guys wanna
wanna put something there may allah
bless you guys for for supporting this
cause
guys hashtag turn back to allah and
hashtag bring
back zach so in a few weeks four months
whenever we got him back
and uh we bring him back on the show you
guys can see an update of what's
actually happening
so a few things that i want to leave all
of you with
number one is that
bro i wonder how many muslims are
actually
willing to die for islam
[Music]
i hope i hope bro i love them but really
i do hope
but that's a question that like it's
legitimate
because there's a lot of people who who
say at face value
or i am muslim and you know of course at
the end of the day the creator is the
only one that knows our true intentions
and like what we really want to do but
it's like
geez like imagine something would have
really happened and like
every single brother that you were
talking to and you think that they were
like down for the cause
and then they just turn on their heels
and they just start running back and it
even says in the quran
the hypocrites so it's like man uh that
stuff for a lot i hope that
most of you know the muslims on days
they are
actually willing to die for the cause
because that's that's something crazy
though i hope they take advantage of the
of the examples that we have you know
the sahaba and the prophet peace be upon
him
just look look at the lives of them how
they were willing to die and how they
died for
for our religion that's the most
beautiful example i can give like
i i look at i listen to their stories
and i cry bro i cry because like
that's a real warrior man one that's
ready to play everything there for for
his creator for the cause of allah
like these these are perfect examples
brother we don't need any we don't need
no superheroes i saw in a comic
like the american the americans have
spider-man have
superman but we have the sahaba brother
we have the prophet peace be upon him
may allah be pleased with all of them
you know i mean
he was on the front lines bro
the front lines like if there was anyone
that's like
trying to do this for power for status
or something bro
they would have seen a war and they
would be like you know what it might not
be best for me to be front lines i'll be
in the war but i'll be in the back over
here
but this man was so about it bro
and it's true what the quran says and it
it's not just about
muslims but you see like i would see
that in the cartels like
the hypocrites the people that weren't
ready they would run bro
to turn them back from running you would
only see a few amount of people standing
straight and fighting for their lives
now imagine when when that happens in
islam when i
because like that my my goal is to reach
those brothers
that i know that are ready to die that
are ready to die for another brother
because that's that's what that's how we
end up making these bonds with these
people
like like i tell a lot of people like
i'm not a crow to fly around with the
flock
i'm an eagle and i fly with evils no
because we have to we have to
we have to be in that status brother we
can't consider ourselves like the rest
of the world
we're not we we got a perfect religion
we we serve the most higher brother
we serve the most high thing we should
be proud of being muslim so you know i'm
proud of being a muslim by that
like i was proud before when i was what
i was and
follow the wrong reasons and the trash
that i wasn't now that i'm a muslim
alhamdulillah for letting me be a part
of this
bro bros so the last thing that i want
to say
and this is something i don't know if
y'all caught this i don't know if it's
going to help but it's something that i
really picked up on
when you were talking about this um but
to
link it all together with what has you
know what has come to me
you you were talking about uh
when you wanted to change when there was
a
that authenticity inside of you that you
wanted to change
that's when you started to really be
guided like you had always been
you already you already had the guidance
but now that you had
you you wanted that change you sincerely
wanted to change
that's when the real change started to
occur in subhanallah
in the quran it even says it in a
certain ayah where it's like
uh allah won't change
anything until you change what's inside
of you that's true
and bro like look at every single person
uh
born muslims reverts
the genuine thing is that they wanted to
change something inside of them
they were looking for some kind of
change it doesn't matter if it was like
oh i want to change uh something about
my character something about my
personality or i want to change
this situation in my life right now or
whatever it is it's just
that sincerity that you wanted to change
and then
because you make that first step what
does allah do bro
you take one step in his direction and
he runs
yeah he comes running boy so um
thoughts comments bro before we wrap it
up i
and immense blessings in the project
insha allah
and i wanted to add if people look at
the link and they're not able to
financially support it just send it to
someone you know can
uh to do on their behalf your behalf for
the sake of allah
share the link in sha allah share the
episodes share this amazing beautiful
story
part one and part two
exactly yes for me personally
subhanallah
it has been a beautiful reminder and
throughout the episode bro i like he he
the brother zach you would say things
and i would think of khalid
subhanallah because subhanallah like
he also came from a position of doing
fighting
fighting a good fight for the wrong
reasons right and when i say a good
fight i mean like
the way he fights and everything he's a
military like strategist masha allah
he's good at what he does even honorable
to some people
to the extent where the prophet islam
asked how is it so that someone so wise
intelligent like khalid hasn't accepted
islam
like it didn't make sense and then
that's when
he came he he first he said to the
prophet salam ask allah to forgive me
because he had done so much wrong so
much bad he couldn't even like believe
it's possible for him to be muslim
and then told him accepting islam wipes
all past sins and he said again just ask
allah to forgive me
the prophet said ask allah to forgive
him he accepted islam and then he made a
180 degree turn
and he fought the same good fights the
same uh you know tough battles for the
sake of islam for the sake of allah
and the way he died he thought he was
going to die in the battlefield there
was not an inch of his body except he
was scarred
from a wound or something he thought he
died on the battlefield but what happens
about allah is he ended up dying from
natural causes in his death bed
and one man came and visited him and he
said you know you're the sword of allah
because that was the name that was
basically giving him he's the sword of
allah
and he's like it doesn't make sense for
the sort of allah to be broken in battle
and it only makes sense that it
basically be retired
and subhanallah i just hearing the story
i thought about that time and time again
so may allah grant you a similar
you know natural passing along life of
allah and
[Music]
it gives me goosebumps to hear about
khalid brother especially
when he talks about that he'd rather be
in battle
then to be with with his wife bro
like when i heard that bro like
goosebumps brother like literally
goosebumps
because i was i was willing to be in
that light then instead of instead of
like a normal person look for look for a
family
because i wasn't why i consider myself a
warrior and now look where i'm at right
now
and i hear in my heart hear all this
brother shh
there's no more there's no one greater
than
all right without further ado
with that being said smash that like
button
and subscribe and subscribe and and
write
write a comment or two before before uh
you guys hop off about what you'd like
to see from zach
any more questions you guys have
something like that all right
that being said allah
i think if somebody wants a good
character
the easiest way the easiest way to
achieve that as fast as possible
is empathy because what is what is good
character good character is a reflection
of who you are and how you treat other
people
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]